[Music]
my personal belief is that as vast as
the universe is our ultimate Destiny is
for human race to become
Interstellar but in order to be able to
do that we need to take steps to get
there and eventually building
technologies that can go beyond our
solar system and Traverse into our
galaxies and then I think to me when you
talk about 10 to 15 years 20 years from
now my hope is that we have a space City
you know place that people actually can
go and
[Music]
live Kim gafarian is an entrepreneur who
has started several space companies his
most well-known company is axium space
which is building what could be the
first commercial space station he's also
built other companies in the space
industry including intuitive machines
which is building lunar Landers and
pursuing commercial commercial missions
to the Moon then there is also Quantum
space which is trying to build a space
super highway to move payloads in CIS
lunar orbit the space between the Earth
and the moon and finally his other main
company is X energy which is building
small modular nuclear reactors which are
far safer and easier to build in smaller
than conventional large nuclear
reactors I was born in Isfahan Iran and
and uh I came to United States when I
was 18 years old with a incredible love
of space programs since childhood I was
just like looking at the stars I'm a
stargazer and just sort of mesmerized
about the stars and can we go there you
know how far are they and really a
transformational moment was when I saw
Neil Armstrong landing on the surface of
the Moon from my neighbors black and
white television and it was like wow
can actually you know go to another
planet and you know and that sort of
really triggered it for me that this is
what I wanted to
do I actually landed in Washington DC
and got myself registered at Catholic
University of America that's where I
worked on my first degree computer
science engineering I came with $2,000
that I borrowed from my uncle to come to
United States so when I came I didn't
have a whole lot of money therefore I
had to work every night in fact I worked
downtown Washington DC parking cars for
the three years that I finished a double
degree program cam gafarian founded Sgt
also known as Stinger gafarian
Technologies in 1994 he co-founded it
with Harold stinger and it was basically
a government contracting business they
did Government Contracting primarily for
NASA and it was the first company he
started after previously working at
lucked Martin and Ford Aerospace it
initially started in his basement he
mortgaged his house to start the company
and over time it grew much larger it
actually started as a section 8A company
which is a federal program for
businesses owned by minorities and it
eventually grew by 2006 it had become
the 20th largest contractor for NASA
with $100 million in contracts and by
the time cam sold it in 2018 it was
worth $355 million when he sold it to
publicly traded
KBR what you're going to hear a whole
lot from me is culture culture culture
and when I say culture it's not just
being ethical or being Integrity based
but a culture of being successful
culture of winning proposals culture
taking care of the people one of the
thing at Sgt that sort of distinguished
us from everybody else was really a
culture and our core values everybody
was says oh it's the ice principles and
ice stood for integrity customers and
employees integrity at the center of
everything that we do bend over backward
to take care of our customers and our
employees are at the heart of everything
that we do that's where that really was
The Key to Our Success at Sgt so people
who join the company wouldn't want to
leave in fact in a period of 23 years
this is sort of incredible I had no
executive that joined the company in 23
years that voluntarily
left the first company I founded after
Sgt in 2009 was X energy and it was
really because of I started a school in
Africa in
Kinshasa and you know I really knew
nothing about nuclear or nothing about
the energy world my I I considered
myself a space cadet and we sponsored
four orphans and and that school now was
grown to like close to 800 people but I
learned that the school didn't have
power right and I learned very quickly
there's a direct relationship between
standard of living around the world and
having electricity so if you don't have
electricity you don't have clean water
you don't have
education and also with all the stuff
that was going on with using the fossil
fuel and you know how much carbon we
generate and you know and we in this
beautiful precious blue globe and if we
don't protect it it's our home if we
don't protect it so far we don't have
another place that we can go that was
the really the Genesis behind X energy
and we've sort of done what I call is
the Holy Grail in nuclear where we
design nuclear reactors that are 100%
safe in the other words if there's a
tsunami or there's an earthquake or any
of that or plane crashes to they can
never go super critical and because of
that you can have them in the middle of
cities or any anywhere and today we are
world leader in advanced nuclear in fact
we won a $25 billion doar Grant from doe
uh to build these nuclear reactors uh is
pretty
incredible the first company founded
after X energy came in 2013 when he
founded intuitive machines which
eventually became a company whose goal
it was to build lunar Landers and really
start to commercialize the moon three
years later came axium space which he
co-founded with Mike saini who was the
longtime director of NASA's
International Space Station program
axium is the company that's building
what could be the first commercial space
station also designing the next
generation of space suits for NASA in
2016 I got together with Michael
safarini who was the previous program
manager for International Space Station
for
NASA and we knew United States
government was not going to build
another space station they were going to
rely on Private Industry to do that so
with this unique experience and my
experience we actually run the operation
of International Space Station
24x7 one of my proud things that I like
to say is when the astronaut from space
talk and say Houston they would be
talking to my company employees and so
was a very bold Vision we built the
first private commercial space station
and that's really that's the vision that
got us started in in 2016 to open the
doors for axium space
after about 30 years at the agency I
started looking around hadn't really
thought a lot about what I was going to
do but there were couple of offers out
there so it got me thinking well maybe
there is another life after this by the
way I had the best job in the whole
agency you know I had a front row seat
to everything that happened on orbit it
was really it was a lot of fun so when I
started thinking about it I cam was one
of those people that had a reputation of
you know being a mover and a Shaker in
the industry and I wanted to seek his
advice just his thoughts on you know
what I should do in my afterlife well if
you know cam you don't s spend a lot of
time talking about things like that I
called him and said you know cam the
only thing I know how to do is build an
operate a space station so you know I've
kind of living in my capabilities so
I'll wait till somebody surely some
company was going to come along and so I
told Cam that I said so I'll wait
somebody will come along and maybe
that's what I'll do and uh and he said
okay let's let's go build a space
station so he seated the company and and
uh we went from there that's that's how
we started together building our space
station axium space has a very ambitious
goal it's to build the world's first
commercial space station they're
actually the only company that's out
there that has the rights to attach
their modules so the the building blocks
of their space station so to speak to
the International Space Station the
first one of those modules is set to go
up in 2026 that's their main goal and
the thing that they're building
currently is the axium space station
however they've already completed two
successful missions to the International
Space Station where they brought
commercial astronauts so people paying
to to be an astronaut and go to the ISS
as well as astronauts from countries
that haven't had the chance to go to
space yet so Saudi Arabia for example
sent two astronauts on the second Axia
Mission my belief is that the ultimate
Destiny for human beings is to go to
stars to actually do the interal travel
to really go to other stars because the
universe is so enormous and vast and in
our galaxy alone there are 400 billion
stars like our sun with planets around
it and there are trillion other galaxies
so we're just such a small part so my
personal belief is that as vast as the
universes our ultimate Destiny is for
human race to become
Interstellar but but in order to be able
to do that we need to take steps to get
there first is Leo lower orbit we need
to have human presence there then going
to the moon and to Mars is you know
further steps having the space
infastructure where you can go from
Earth to the Moon and Beyond is another
thing and so these companies all follow
that larger
Vision so one thing that always came up
with the I think more than a dozen
people I spoke to about cam is that he's
really ambitious which you kind of get
just from learning about the companies
he's built but also that he's able to
convince people and motivate them to
actually get those very ambitious
projects done you know you look at the
incredible amount of EX NASA sort of
rock stars he's brought over people who
were leading their fields and he
convinced them to come to the private
sector and build these companies he went
with ax energy from not knowing anything
about energy to now being one of the
leading companies in nuclear energy
right and these new reactors that could
really make a huge difference in
renewable energy goals and obviously the
jury is still out anything could could
happen in in the future there's a lot of
competition out there it's still a
speculative market right for space
stations and for a lot of these things
but when you look at sort of his initial
dreams and Visions commercial L Landers
commercial space station the nuclear
reactors where he's been able to take
those ideas in terms of the funding and
the people he's brought with him
and turning them into real businesses
that's really impressive and that really
stood out to me when I was talking to
him and the people who have known him
for a long time I really hope that my
legacy is that I contributed to advanc
the state of humanity and human
knowledge which is really the vision
that I've had for many years including
Sgt to know that someone maybe breeded
easier as a result of you you've lived
through my philantropic activities and
also making a difference for our planet
like with X energy so that children can
survive the climate change and
everything else so making a difference
and making this planet and also going to
other places a better place for
us